so this month i'm focusing a little bit
on increasing my focus so therefore i
read all books on motivation and focus
and how to increase those and i found
this book called the one thing that i
really liked and with this book i
learned a few lessons that hopefully you
can apply as well if you're doing your
phd right now or if you're a student and
let's get right into it so hi i'm
schloss fraser a phd student in
computational neuroscience at the donors
institute in the netherlands and today i
want to talk about the four lessons i
learned from this book called the one
thing and i think in general it is a
really enjoyable book so if you want to
learn a little bit more i also highly
recommend to read it but let's get
straight into the first lesson that i
learned so the first thing the book
talks about is the myth of to-do lists
and i actually really like this because
the idea is that to-do lists if you make
them you just put everything that you
have to do in that day but the pitfall
with to-do list that i've also noticed
in myself is that it's really easy to
just start doing these tiny little tasks
that clutter up your to-do list like for
example replying to emails or doing the
grocery shopping or texting back this
one friend and although these are valid
things you have to do in a day these are
not the most important thing and
especially not for your research or if
you're a student for studying and it's
really easy to feel really good at the
end of the day if you crossed off all
these tiny to-do's but you haven't
really done anything significant for
your major goals which are your research
or finishing your studies and therefore
i think this is a really valid point
that the myth of to-do list that they
make you really productive so the book
then goes into the burrito principle and
the burrito principle is that eighty
percent of all your output is actually
produced by just 20 of your input so
probably if you're studying all day all
the studying is
mainly a lot of reading or a lot of
looking at lectures online but the
actual studying where you recall the
information is probably only about two
hours every day if you study for 10
hours and the same thing is if you're
doing research right now i notice it
with myself that i can spend a lot of
time watching lectures or reading papers
but the actual work that i need to do is
usually only around two hours every day
so with the burrito principle you kind
of if you put all the tasks you need to
do you can kind of see which are the 20
that are actually giving the results and
once you've found those you can focus
more on those and the book the one thing
actually goes further and they say that
you really have to zoom in even more and
find every day that one thing that you
can do in your project or in your
company that will give you the most
return value and i do think in a sense
this is a little bit an
oversimplification because of course
there are many things you could do or
many things that would be beneficial but
i do think in a period when you're
feeling a little bit overwhelmed and
you're not really sure which way to go
should i go to b or a and you're not
making any choices then i think it's
really good to focus down on just one
thing and that's why this week i try to
do that because i am feeling a little
bit overwhelmed in my research right now
because there are just so many
possibilities i could go
towards so yeah i decided every day in
the morning to just pick one thing i had
to do that day and which
would be the most important for my
research and then only focus on
completing that one task and in the
afternoon or in the evening if i
finished it i could do anything i want
so i could watch some lectures or i
could also have some leisure time if i
wanted to and i do think this helped a
lot like it made me feel at least a
little bit accomplished every day and
kind of gave me that dopamine boost that
i needed to continue my research so the
second lesson he goes into is the myth
of willpower and i personally really
agree with this and you probably noticed
it as well that if you have to use your
willpower a lot during the day it's
actually depleted quite quickly so if
you want to do many things that require
willpower during the day the probability
of you doing those things late in the
day are very slim to none
so if you think of your tasks and you
see a lot of them require willpower you
have to kind of calculate this in and
also for me the thing i noticed the most
is that because i'm working at home in
my office all day there's so much
temptation to just get a snack or to
watch youtube for a little bit and to
resist this actually requires a lot of
willpower so that's why next week mainly
i want to see if i can change up my
environment a little bit because even
though university is closed right now
where i live the cafes are still open or
i could go to friends and i think by
being around people that are also a
little bit focused i need to use less of
my willpower to stay focused and the
third lesson i learned from this book is
the myth of a work-life balance so the
fact with balance is that we kind of
feel that once we've achieved balance
then we're there we're set we're good to
go we have achieved the pinnacle of life
but the thing is with balance that you
can kind of go in and out of it quite
quickly so for example if you do yoga
and you do the three pose then you know
that staying in the tree pose actually
requires a lot of mental effort and also
for your body to keep adjusting itself
to keep standing and the same thing is
with work life balance he explains in
the book so work life balance is a
constant struggle between leaning too
much in to your work at periods of time
and leaning too much into your personal
relationships or for example your
hobbies and i think this is true i think
there are just periods in your life that
you are more focused on your work or
you're a little bit stressed for your
studies and you need to study for a
continuous week but then it's really
important to also go back to being a
little bit more focused on your own
personal life so for example if you have
a stressful period for one month it's
really nice to then block in a small
holiday or or a longer weekend that you
can really reconnect with your hobbies
or with your friends and that is kind of
what balance is so balance is not really
set on an everyday level and it's also
different per individual so some people
need to see a lot of people or have a
lot of relationships whereas other
people
are okay to work actually quite a lot
and don't
need that much balance in that sense but
one thing he also talks about which i
thought was really good is that if life
is kind of like juggling all these
different facets in our life so for
example work friends family your health
then work is kind of like a rubber ball
if you drop it during the juggling it
will bounce back up if you pick it up
again but family and friends in your
health are kind of like glass balls so
if you drop them they actually scatter
or shatter and i think this is actually
really true because you cannot just
leave your friends and your family for
one year and expect them to just be
waiting for you unless you have really
good friends or family but these are
actually continuous relationships that
you need to work on so for example if
you have children if you miss the first
years of their life you cannot really
get those back whereas with work i think
you can always start again and but this
could be personal i think just in the
end life is not work you really it's
more relationships and friends and
family and also your health so these are
things you should never fully drop even
during periods that you feel you need to
work really hard so yeah and then the
last thing he talks about is to find
that one thing that you can do and i
think he recommends a really interesting
exercise and it kind of goes like this
so you think of the next five years
what's the one thing you want to do that
you think will change your life so for
me that's of course getting my phd
finally oh my god and then the next step
is to go a little bit smaller so what's
the one thing you can do this year that
will help you achieve that goal so for
me it would be something like writing
one paper this year although the year is
almost over so i won't finish that but
next year and then you go even smaller
so what's the one thing you can do this
month that will help you achieve this
goal what's the one thing you can do
this week what's the one thing you can
do this day and then what's the one
thing you can do this hour and i think
this is a really interesting exercise
that you can do with every point of your
life that you find important so for
example you could also think of friends
and family what's the thing i want to do
the next five years that would really
increase my value of the relationships
that i have and then go smaller like
that and i think by going through this
exercise everything that you kind of
want in life becomes suddenly very
tangible and very reachable and that's
why i do think it's a really nice
exercise so yeah to try to find your one
thing and if you're struggling a little
bit with motivation and feeling a little
bit burned out during your phd i did
make another video about it so you can
check that out right here and otherwise
see you next week for another focus
motivation video so see you bye